[Music]
as you uh have noted from the opening
public schools in virginia especially
are an unmitigated disaster maybe it's
the proximity to dc that's the problem
dc is the intellectual and spiritual
equivalent of a malfunctioning nuclear
reactor everybody in the vicinity is
soaking up the metaphorical radiation
and getting sick and that brings us to
blacksburg high school in montgomery
county in virginia where a teacher josh
thompson according to fox news
has been posting tick tock videos to
share his views on white supremacy and
racism in one video he says that
whiteness is not a race but a racial
ideology listen
this is an idea that i think a lot of
people have um and i want to call that
in uh lovingly just for a moment yes
america contains many cultures and many
races that is not wrong
however
the problem comes when we don't think
about this idea or this argument in a
racialized way when it comes to power
and power dynamics
in america as in many other parts of the
western world whiteness is the dominant
racial
ideology
so we think of power in terms of race
whiteness has the most power
so while there are people of many
different races and cultures living in
america the fact that whiteness is the
dominant racialized power structure
that is the problem and that is why we
have to involve race in all of our
arguments and considerations
this is not really the point but i have
to say i'm always annoyed and a bit
perplexed by the number of cuts and
edits these tick talkers need for a one
minute video
there's a cut after every sentence
they're not able to string together two
sentences at once i speak for an hour
straight on this show with no cuts at
all many of my sentences may be rambling
and unnecessary but at least i can put
multiple sentences together
these people have to cut and think about
the next sentence before filming and
still it ends up being incoherent
but the greater point is that this
teacher is a self-hating white freak
subjecting students to his intellectual
masochism and it gets worse listen to
josh thompson's take on pbis pbis which
stands for positive behavioral
interventions and supports and is the
framework used in virginia schools for
dealing with behavior problems now it
already sounds like permissive new age
nonsense
but uh it's still not enough for josh
apparently who believes that any attempt
to control a student's behavior is you
guessed it white supremacy
i made a comment on one of miss april's
recent videos about pbis in which i
stated that pbis is white supremacy with
the hug and a lot of y'all wanted to
know more about that so here we go
first of all thank you to jack koppa who
um reminded me that
dina simmons was the first to coin this
term so thank you jack so much
so if pbis concerns itself with positive
behaviors um we have to ask ourselves
okay well what are those positive
behaviors and it's things like making
sure that you're following directions
and making sure that you're sitting
quietly and you are in your seat and all
these things that come from
white culture
the idea of just sitting quiet and being
told stuff and taking things in in a
passive stance is not a thing that's in
with many cultures so if we're
positively enforcing these behaviors we
are by extension positively enforcing
elements of white culture which
therefore keeps whiteness at the center
which is the definition of white
supremacy
a smarmy little squirrel this guy is
they really all are
and hey i thought what do you mean white
culture i thought white people didn't
have a culture
which is it
when they need to make uh a point like
this
suddenly we as white people have a
culture but
in any other context we don't that's why
they say
you're not allowed to express pride in
being white
you know any expression of white pride
is racism
um and you can't you you can't say that
well no i i just am i'm proud of my
culture if you say that they'll say
there's no such thing as white culture
but now you're saying there is white
culture and part of white culture is
children
you know following directions and
behaving well
that sounds like a good culture can i be
proud of that
doesn't make any sense but the idea here
is that students the idea is that if
students have to sit quietly and behave
themselves and follow directions that's
something that comes from white culture
this teacher has apparently aside from
all the other contradictions decided
that the entire continent of asia does
not exist
classrooms in many parts of asia are far
more far more focused on discipline than
any classroom in the united states
that's why the average student in china
can perform calculus and build a working
space shuttle by like second grade
but josh thompson says that only white
people expect kids to behave which is
once again
the bigotry of low expectations or no
expectations
rearing its head
because the obvious implication here is
that non-white students can't be
expected to behave properly or are not
capable of it
this is not only incredibly demeaning
but it's also plainly false you'll
notice how
the crt cult makes sweeping assertions
about the nature of whiteness and and
the things that derive from whiteness
but they never make any attempt to prove
any of these assertions
this is what makes it fun and easy to be
a member of the cult it's perhaps the
primary attraction it almost makes me
want to join the cult sometimes
sometimes i want to to be a member of
the crt cult for this reason because it
just ha it must be so great
to be able to make any wild claim you
want and never be asked to justify it or
provide any evidence whatsoever
you can stand up and shout and say
spatulas are racist if you use a spatula
you're partaking in white supremacy
and everybody just nods their head and
says wow i never realized that this
common kitchen instrument was racist i
didn't know that i was involving myself
in a nazi conspiracy every time i flip a
pancake my god i'm so ashamed
nobody stops and says what where are you
getting that who told you this
this is the sort of privilege afforded
to the left-wing race hustlers
with all that said
he is actually getting somewhere
within the vicinity of an important
truth
he's wrong about it being a white
supremacist ploy to tell kids to behave
themselves he's wrong about all the
racial aspects of this but he is correct
that the public school system uses a
passive quiet calm
memorization and regurgitation method of
education
it fails in that method most of the time
i mean you walk into the average public
school classroom and it's anything but
but but calm and quiet and organized
but that is the the method that the
entire system is built around
the reason why public school classrooms
are dysfunctional is because in order to
function they need all the kids to be
behaving this way but none of them
really are
and you know in fairness if you're going
to try to educate thousands of kids at a
time on a kind of industrialized
assembly line taking them from one class
to the next in 45 minute increments for
seven hours a day then you really have
no choice but to go about it this way
doesn't it doesn't work they have to
drug the kids half the kids just to make
it work and it still doesn't work but
public schools as they are currently
constructed really have no other choice
none of this has anything to do with
whiteness
and it isn't designed for white kids it
is rather as i have observed many times
including recently
it is rather designed for girls
girls thrive in that kind of educational
environment because they're better at
memorization they're better at sitting
still they're better at learning in that
way
which is why k which is why girls do
better in public schools why more girls
are going to college it's why fewer
girls are drugged
education is not too white
it's too feminine
but josh thompson's ideology may allow
him sometimes to get a whiff of the real
problem to come close to identifying yet
it won't allow him to correctly diagnose
it
or prescribe the right remedies for it
and that is why he is today i must say
officially cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content